it's time to babble the [ __ ] live from
the Jon Lovitz aah gasps Peter it's
Hollywood babble-on
with your host Kevin Smith and Ralph
Garman
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah there we go
yes how it's gonna be huh yeah oh [ __ ]
it is Saturday night in Hollywood so
let's babble the [ __ ] on I'm Kevin Smith
I'm Ralph Garman Wow
yet another sold-out house here at the
Jon Lovitz absolutely can you tear my
[ __ ] up man is that possible jacket not
like I never thought I'd say this but we
get Kevin a little higher speaking of
which Ben there you go I'm in the show
like a man yeah I figured what strain of
the evening man comes all the way from
San Francisco San Fran stood over there
[Music]
bubble cush man from our good friend
will a little bit of bubble could push
yeah yeah so I'm on fire tonight I'm in
charge and [ __ ] bubble cush put you in
charge does it not really lead the show
cuz all right how you been making before
we get [ __ ] started I know I'm Way
late on [ __ ] and this is yet another
thing I'm late on but it's good cuz
[ __ ] could watch it right now
they could pause our show download and
watch or go pick up the DVD or bluray
have you seen Dredd Oh Brad yeah oh so
[ __ ] good man it was and what was
beautiful about it to me was it was done
within a budget like that's a low-budget
comic-book movie man like there
sometimes they'll just run around
hallways where it's like a hanna-barbera
call wait before I got big that's all
that yeah it's like in the matrix and
[ __ ] but
is fantastic they did such a [ __ ]
great job so true to the book Karl Urban
is wonderful everything about it is
[ __ ] cool did you see I did see it
yes [ __ ] a year ago right happen so
when people were still talking about it
actually I'm trying to restart the
conversation I'm like you gotta got late
to the party I'm like what are you guys
talking about have you tried this punch
it's awesome I know we've been drinking
it for about four hours you guys know
what alcohol is I watch this on a plane
dude and I was the audibly appreciative
of it like an urban audience member or
something like punch him in the [ __ ]
mouth and he would do it wow that's
great
what's this because nobody [ __ ] yells
at me on a plane anymore because they're
all scared together
I swear dude almost look South went out
of business last time I love the people
of Virgin America Megas every flight
doesn't matter like I usually sit kind
of in the front and the bulkhead or
whatever and I just sues the plane takes
off they turn off the seatbelt sign I
just sit on the floor right next to my
chair and I put a blanket on me so
people don't see the job of roles right
yeah and never once have they been like
this is against the law you know they're
never like get the [ __ ] up man this
ain't no bow Airlines and [ __ ] they just
let me be comfortable I think that's
because everyone's afraid that if
they're like you're gonna have to get up
I'm like don't make me go to Twitter
don't bully a bad boy on Twitter
now I've got my friend Instagram to
double-barrelled I'll make you famous
but I wish they'd thank him what do you
watch acid red that looks fun and [ __ ]
as opposed to like shut up yeah
but it's good it's so worth your time go
check it I'm sorry I'm late on it no
it's okay that's it not the backtrack
but you sit on the floor in a plane
[Laughter]
[ __ ] man I just stay out of chairs as
quickly as I can
the moment they take the seat belt sign
up I just sit on the floor and [ __ ] so
that nobody will come over and be like
you gotta buy two of those boys two
floors I'm hard pressed to see how
that's more comfortable chairs sitting
on the floor of an airplane there's
enough legroom and [ __ ] and it's awesome
because you're not like when you're
playing you're facing this way right
like you know like you travel in a car
or anything when you're sitting on the
floor you're travelling to the side and
[ __ ] you just feel like you're sliding
through time that's cuz I'm baked before
I got on the plane all right whatever
you need big weekend this weekend not
not here well here of course tonight
it's a big weekend but big weekend down
in Anaheim one of my friends are
tweeting and texting me from the
WonderCon wonderful Oh wonder continent
going on right now as we speak for those
unfamiliar with the communities a sister
con to the San Diego Comic Con or Comic
Con International fantastic mostly
creator base you have a better chance of
meeting people who do your favorite
books and stuff artists writers not so
much Hollywood hype and one huh yeah so
people say it's great as any one here
tonight gone today
well thanks for coming back to see us we
appreciate we're gonna have a little bit
of a geek bent throughout the show
tonight in honor of comic-con going on
where is this geek and we're willing
event no just sort of sort of a theme as
we go through some of our recurring
weekly segment there'll be a lot to them
speaking of weekly segments let's start
off with one we look forward to each and
every week where we say hi to some
people celebrating special occasions or
have come particularly long distances
each and every week it's called the
shout outs
it's a shout out Kevin around so get
your [ __ ] out
[Music]
Wow
let's try this rolling technique you
really love and that one usually you're
sort of lustful about it but that was
romantic okay I call it the picture
pages man cuz I got a big marker I'm
like ah drawn a smile on my face with a
dick is Carolyn from Vancouver here not
the right country they [ __ ] counts
welcome from Vancouver this starts this
email starts it's from Alex by the way
your boyfriend or at least he was until
you got here I know what you've been
doing since you arrived
my girlfriend Carolyn is coming out to
HBO from Vancouver she's an awesome
person I wish I could be there with her
in a couple months she will be there
remounting watering hole that's almost
game dirty
Alex adds it's not nearly as dirty as it
sounds oh because she has a dance
company and watering hole is one of the
show she has choreographed oh so you're
a choreographer oh you must be flexible
as [ __ ]
I dated a dancer once all kinds of crazy
positions are capable with a dancer too
[ __ ] out here like what yeah
use your imagination draw you a picture
yeah alex says good Jerry Lewis wish her
luck with her production well of course
he could he probably wouldn't cuz he's a
miserable old [ __ ] but we can make
Alex's dream come true so you're working
on a show called watering hole what the
[ __ ] kind of show is that I have - you
know there's kids who can't walk for
[ __ ] sake
there you are dancing on a stage around
a hole full of water crazy lady
water a hall of live in Hawaii I just
[ __ ] myself there you go little love
from Carrie how about Matt and Jamie you
you guys here tonight Matt and Jamie
where where over there my name is Matt
I'll be tending the show on March 30th
with my lovely wife Jamie celebrating
our one-year anniversary Oh
congratulations you guys [ __ ] what
do you want to look at their marriage
certificate I believe they did married
for a year that's the guy that wanted to
marry Jamie this bird lover he's bucking
Matt's Lex Luthor man
followed their life in crowds and [ __ ]
if anyone addresses and he's like
[ __ ] horse shadow my life Matt steal
your glory my wife is so awesome that
not only she coming to Babylon is an HBO
virgin but she also bought us three-day
WonderCon passes to celebrate as well
she's a fan of PBS well she shouldn't be
an HBO if she likes PBS were the
opposite I wonder if you could have
Huell Howser tell her how amazing she is
and wish her happy anniversary Jamie you
are amazing you took out your wallet and
you paid for tickets for a show and then
you took it out again and you paid for
tickets for a convention you're amazing
there you go liberal with her catch that
Jamie look I want see angry let me see
Stern Huell Howser at her tell her tell
her husband wait she bought the tickets
for him Jamie bought the tickets for
Matt tell her husband he's got a paint a
smile on her [ __ ] with his dick I don't
think that's fuels breed of conversation
do it mule
so mad as a thank you to Jamie I think
it'd be great if you'd pay a smile face
[Laughter]
on her plate with your [ __ ] Hawks are
amazing believe me Hewlett no you're
right he wasn't gay my bad
wake the [ __ ] up you people stop it no
idea like a $3 bill that guy that's
amazing you know what you can fit up the
human sphincter in Alba Cod oh it's
amazing
[Laughter]
pie is here pie are you near how's your
life by Richard Park but you never heard
that joke before did your pie he's like
my name used to be cool this [ __ ]
movie that was going ah
I'm from Albuquerque New Mexico pyrites
celebrating my 27th birthday here with
you guys in town by myself because all
my friends are [ __ ] right on man way
to stick it to the friends who don't
give a [ __ ] they ditched me last minute
before making the trip out here but that
hasn't bothered me from having the
weekend of a lifetime what you do if I
saw a cool band when both things by
herself happy sad birthday
we uh we got there's anybody else here
by themselves perhaps as some woody into
God theater singles guys or girls girls
be sure welcome Los Angeles put a dick
in your mouth hi let me tell you guys
are amazing any other Singleton's in the
crowd anybody else here by themselves by
a [ __ ] bail of that smoke nothing
else you are silly good for a power shut
up PI says I was hoping you give me a
shout out during the March thirtieth
show I think we we did that
significantly PI he also would like to
hear the Al Pacino more margaritas song
now before it became our Hollywood
helper theme song it did exist in a life
of its own as the more margaritas on one
of our faithful listeners put it to
music and had al pacino talking about
more margaritas to a tune and I think
that's what pies looking for so I think
it's only fair
[Music]
Margarita's oh we need like a dance mix
of that we'd make a million dollars I
could honestly if you put that on loop
I'll just make it out all day long
okay the next shout out is for a Herbert
Maria Rosa Lucy it's to Herbert Maria
you [ __ ] missed that cuz you were so
into booze it's very nice you bought me
this show who was the person but who
what we're back over there thank you so
much I appreciate it
my liver thinks he was well this email
comes from a Herbert Maria Rosa and Lucy
and they are here celebrating nothing
all right Lucy writes I don't know if
this will reach you in time for
tomorrow's show but I'm tending with my
husband Herbert my sister Maria my
cousin Rosa visiting all the way from
the Hyatt ending with Herbert Maria oh
the rest to see me I think we need some
sad Hulk music me a little sad Hulk
recently my cousin Rosa has been a
little depressed because she met a guy
she really liked but he turned out to be
hiding a really big secret from her
we had a vagina I'm kidding Oh that'd be
great Oh getting ready to tug it right
now I was like [ __ ] out here I knew
that's not to be made light up this is a
bad stomach a little bit he turned out
to be married
not nearly as sexy but separated well
needless to say the relationship did not
pan out and Rosa was very sad about it
have you met pie Rosa
Yeah Yeah right up here
it's a whipped cream on that book Alamo
I was wondering if you could cheer her
up by having Edwin let her know that she
deserves so much better than that prick
list [ __ ] also my sister Maria thinks
Kevin is sexy
can you have him say hello to her in his
sexy voice girl whoa
Maria the sister thinks you're sexy Rosa
was the one with the quickest [ __ ]
can't do that get hit on one person and
then like but gonna be like I'm sorry
and hit on the person next oh [ __ ] my
Jason Mewes alright oh my goodness Rosa
here's the thing not every man is a pig
just looking to stick his penis into any
warm wet holy can find all right every
man is like that but the key is to find
one that's not married you see or one
that doesn't have a vagina
because I heard earlier about that guy
and it's a mess don't you know but don't
worry life is for the living and as far
as I can tell you still living right
there we go seriously man part one
separated by one fly really I just have
a drink with each other man hey quick
hand job the parking lot
maybe a little diddle you know whatever
the [ __ ] it's all good at the love it
[Laughter]
that should be on a shirt it's all good
at the lovin
Kerra Brian Danielle and Jacob hey only
one of you is happy to be here my
husband Brian are here for our second
HBO show rights Kara along with my
sister Danielle and her husband Jacob
they're visiting here from Nebraska well
welcome
wow man Nebraska right on don't take
offense if Danielle gets up to puke
during the show
she's bulimic no I'm kidding I'm kidding
she's not bulimic shut up she's in the
wonderful first trimester of pregnancy
oma huh
[Music]
Nebraska see how traveled though ya know
it's like it tripped like a cracked egg
on a head it would just seep down and so
people got it can you please have Alpha
Chi know tell them to move the [ __ ] back
to California ready we missed them what
are you thinking living in Nebraska
Nebraska is 2 States what media is
dating give me credit for that walk it's
all you buddy
oh and by oh ma oh you know it you're
gonna hate me but I missed this part
because they spelled it wrong maybe bank
and say quick congratulations to them on
the upcoming baby oh I hope you have a
lovely child and lastly for the
shoutouts caleb scott max Lucas Anthony
and Greg they're not here you [ __ ]
they were the ones we're gonna ask for
David Bowie
that hurts but you know what I know why
they're not here because they're they're
starting off the bachelor party with the
show here tonight oh I probably got
caught up and [ __ ] yeah they're balls
deep in hookers by now good for them
maybe I can do an angry David Bowie the
fact they didn't show maybe that's the
[Music]
[Applause]
[ __ ] you --fill not be you here [ __ ] you
caleb scott madden Lou
[ __ ] your attorney Greg and just an I
hope you catch up in the real disease
from the hookers that's your [ __ ] and
the blow that you are doing your
bachelor party's ruined by a heart
attack one of you has I say Scott max
Lucas son just saying you're going to
keep
[Music]
Kevin will be performing that at the
bachelor party later on this evening
keep doing that dance form would you
like to have a seat on the ground here
get comfortable okay it just makes me
giggle cause like I stood on a stage and
can once oh my god I'm sucking my own
boob in we get emails from all around
the world as well it's my email bag
[Music]
featuring Kevin's reactions
Jared Thor bond writes I saw this photo
of Justin Bieber and did a double take
because it's at first I thought it was
the star of one of my favorite movies
I'm gonna put this picture up for you so
you can see for yourself what Jared was
talking about it's Justin Bieber here
it's Janine from ghostbusters on the
other side like she should be running
the things at the fire station they're
ghost people what do you want
Janine from ghostbusters like totally
Sally Jessy Raphael Frank yeah he's got
swag yo he's not melting down oh well
your mom's getting stood up to Michael
Leahy when I was in [ __ ] fourth grade
and for the next three grades people
were like don't mess with Kevin his mom
might show in retrospect that would have
taken the ass-beating any day man just
to hold on to that [ __ ] dignity
because my muscle became my mother you
know you leave Tiger alone she will
lecture you to death buddy Danny bowling
of Greenfield Massachusetts writes in my
name is Danny been listening since
episode 1 probably listening to the
entire podcast library about 3 or 4
times the other night I was rereading
Ultimates Comics x-men number 10 when I
was surprised to see a familiar looking
face on page 5 the first panel it takes
place in a mutant containment camp do
you know who this is he writes this guy
I never knew you were a mutant
containment camp I try not to talk about
that time
what was your mutant power the blob did
you know you were featured in the next
men cute you are there no look I'm a
living cartoon but I'm so much thinner
yeah they're starving you in that camp
yeah she call the Geneva Convention and
get a meal or two that's horrible
well that's your embarrassment here's
mine yeah my name is Pedro I am talking
from Brazil he writes not awesome
English [ __ ] language learning Pedro
he's not talking from Brazil he's
[ __ ] writing from Brazil 42 on the
screen and for the price of a cup of
coffee a day we can feed him and his
family isn't he's a grown [ __ ] man
writing an email started listening to
HBO a couple months ago still halfway
through the entire run through an
episode 42 a guy found a clip of Ralph
Garman on Doogie Howser yeah we did do
that once where we're gonna do an
ongoing bit called garbage with all
their Ralph Garman bits of me on my
horrible TV career I'm still lost on the
visual of Ralph Garman on Doogie Howser
yeah I was an EMT man oh I thought he
meant on duty no stop it a very special
episode and [ __ ] where one of the other
doctors was like hey dude you're amazing
I also found out he was in one episode
of highway to heaven we were just
talking about that a couple weeks ago I
worked with Michael Landon in 1988 on
the show called highway to heaven and we
hit it off on the set stop it and he
said well I'm doing another show and I
got another stuff coming up I'd like to
work with you again and then he promptly
died after that so yeah it was very sad
he was he was he was a nice guy but this
guy sadly to my chagrin found the
episode that I was in highway to heaven
and sent in a clip
me from 1988 once again working in a
hospital Thank You [ __ ] Pedro for
this this is a clip of me from highway
to heaven playing a naval corpsman at a
hospital from 1988 can we throw up a
skill it is a screencap of me in that
role in case you missed it because it
was 30 seconds look at how young and
beautiful I was you must have been like
[ __ ] beside yourself man I'm like
that was a show that a lot of people saw
I was the biggest show on NBC and look
how young and hopeful and still looking
forward to my life I was at that time
breaking the bittered [ __ ] drunk you
see before you tonight it's true man I
thought I knew you in 1988 and [ __ ] I
saw Doogie Howser and you were on I'd be
like this guy's living the [ __ ] dream
and [ __ ] not everyone gets to be [ __ ]
doobie man sometimes you're the guy
who's like he's sick and then you're
awesome you must have been like so
[ __ ] I was I was excited I was very
poor and I was very happy to have the
job actually at that moment you know
it's weird dude when I worked at quick
stop there's no [ __ ] lie I watched
that show religiously you might have
seen me while I watched that episode and
never [ __ ] thought one day I'll be
sitting next to that guy see that guy
there someday I will give him no lines
in a movie that's like your show I'll
tell you I'll take that something I'm
more than made up for it I've been
writing clerks three four
[Applause]
it's been so much fun that you have
hands down I've read it of course
because I'm working on it
I've only let two people read it so far
my wife Jennifer who is like hates
everything funny in the world no she's
actually pretty good judge economy she's
not a huge fan of my stuff but that's
why it was pretty good to put it in
front of her and then Brian Johnson the
guy my friend Brian yeah so both of them
have read it and they both agree I'm not
gonna go into what they said because
naturally they like me they're
predisposed to like it but the [ __ ]
thing that I was so delighted both of
them said was there's a moment that you
have that both of them listed in their
top two funniest moments in the whole
flick that when this happens that is
[ __ ] hysterical I was like I
literally laughed out loud writing it
man because I thought a garment I was so
you've got you got not only do you have
lines you also have what the very select
group who've read it so far I think is
one of the funniest moments of them yeah
I'm a hobo get set on fire or something
right Joel Sutton from Monroe Louisiana
writes in listen to this show every week
helps me keep my sanity while dealing
with my daily deeds it would be nice if
Ralph could do me a solid and tell me
what it'd be like for Harrison Ford to
have a total meltdown and do the
Christian Bale rant this Christian Bale
rain has taken on a life of its own it's
Christian Bale on the set of Terminator
5 whatever the [ __ ] it was salvation
yeah and it's it was audio captured on
the set of him melting down against the
guy who was the DP I guess and he goes
off on him and we've done it several
different people taking their shots at
the Christian Bale rant which is oh good
for you
oh come on come to your place but do I
go mess with your life to go lovey dog
no no no we are done professionally made
that's basically the rent and he wants
to hear it as Harrison Ford which is
gonna be hard to do
this pit will need a theme song very I
think it will yeah no no no you and I
have done professionally there you go
there's the Kristen Bell rent and
speaking of its we do each and every
week people been writing and asking for
the Green Lantern's oath that he uses to
recharge his power ring each and every
week in a different voice this is this
week's
[Music]
[Music]
this week South comes from Pablo
Hernandez from Oxnard California in the
spirit of this year's Oscar tribute to
James Bond I would love to hear Sir Sean
Connery recite the Green Lantern oath
thank you and keep up the great work
Pablo Hernandez Oxnard California in
brightest day or blackest night no evil
shall escape my sight let those who
worship evils might beware my power go
[ __ ] yourself
hey Gunn he would have made a great
Green Lantern Sean Connery he wouldn't
go in tomorrow yes every week we take a
look at people and show business who
have passed on who have left us in the
past week who left behind huge bodies of
work that we still will appreciate long
after they're gone you like to give them
a little send-off it's called the tinsel
town stiffs
[Music]
they will be missed bunch of people left
us this week starting with Grammy
winning producer Phil Ramone is dead at
the age of 72 I'm not familiar with this
gentleman's name you're not familiar
with his name maybe but you're familiar
with his work he won 14 Grammys as a
producer oh he was looking lor including
three record and albums of the year he
worked with Burt Bacharach Bono Ray
Charles Bob Dylan Aretha Franklin Quincy
Jones Madonna Paul McCartney Paul Simon
Frank Sinatra and Stevie Wonder just the
name of you I'm sure that dude was like
I'm not familiar with their [ __ ] name
Fat Boy he did a lot of work with Billy
Joel produced all of his records when he
was with his soundtracks that he
produced Flashdance Ghostbusters and
Midnight Cowboy did all that as well
those are two my favorite soundtracks
he's a massive massive talent and now
has passed away at the age of 72 big
bucket a win indeed well we're talking
about people who did an enormous amount
of work in their lifetime a trumpeter by
the name of Derek Watkins passed away
this week you don't know his name he was
a session players one of these guys was
always super talented loved by other
professionals in his industry would
bring him into the recording studio to
lay down tracks because they knew they
could count on him he did work with well
people like the Beatles he played the
trumpet parts on Strawberry Fields
forever and Penny Lane he did that
oh he worked with Frank Sinatra Barbra
Streisand Elton John
u2 Eric Clapton Dizzy Gillespie Placido
Domingo Robbie Williams Oasis but his
real claim to fame is he played on every
soundtrack of every James Bond movie in
the history of the franchise when he was
17 years old he worked on a movie called
doctor no and this is the sound he
played on that soundtrack
he played the lead trumpet part and
every soundtrack to every James Bond
film from that till Skyfall he was the
guy huge cauldron a win that's the way
it's 68 this week after a two-year
battle with cancer which I [ __ ] don't
like by the way I want to go on the
record and say I am anti cancer I'm
sorry I had to take a stand and I want
to say to you can look at my face and
I'm saying this out loud to you person
to person I am against cancer yeah okay
how you [ __ ] carry Jim Carrey hates
guns you ain't came that's right
taking a stand Derrick also played on
the mummy Basic Instinct Indiana Jones
all those films gladiator a Superman 1 &
2 imagine doing something in your body
of work that's gonna live on for [ __ ]
ever mmm yeah [ __ ] cop out yeah well
sure we got that I know you've got a
soft spot Kevin Kevin for write writers
in your life yeah Don Payne passed away
this week you may not know that name
either but he was one of the creative
minds behind the Simpsons he was one of
people who made the Simpsons as
successful as they were he won four
Emmys for his work on The Simpsons
passed away this week also wrote Thor
Thor to the one they're gonna be working
on he was a big geek row Fantastic Four
rise of the Silver Surfer and was a very
talented funny man who wrote a lot of
great screenplays as well as all those
Simpson notes he wrote I like to work
quite a bit I guess and my super
ex-girlfriend had moments as well he
wrote that as well
he'll be missed and the Simpsons come on
better now generations a comedy to come
huge bucket a win on that guy
Gordon Stoker passed away this week he
was a member of perhaps the most
successful backup band in the history of
music he was one of the Jordanaires you
know the Jordanaires were and they sing
with Elvis they backed up Elvis for 14
years on stage and on record
he also backed up with the Jordanaires
Patsy Cline on the song crazy Kenny
Rogers on the song Lucille and George
Jones on he stopped loving her today oh
my god I love he's all the background
voices they're doing my father was a
huge George Joan that really
subsequently made me a somewhat of a
George Jones fans as well
they met Elvis in 1955 they were an
established gospel group already they
performed he was unknown in 55 he saw
them and said if I ever get anywhere in
this business if I ever get a record
deal that's worth anything I will hire
you guys to come in and record with me
and they said [ __ ] off greaser no they
didn't they were all good Christian boys
they said well that's very nice son then
they kicked him in the balls No so he
went off and he signs with RCA a year
later and he's the biggest recording
star in the world in 1956 and sure
enough he was true to his word he finds
them and brings them into the studio and
makes them his backup singers not only
for that year but for the next 14 years
till 1970 they were working together to
make me cry that's so sweet a great
story here's a little piece of the Ed
Sullivan Show with Elvis on it and
behind them in the horrible checkered
suit jackets you can see the Jordanaires
backing him up on don't be cruel
they go something like this pretty cool
passed away this week at 88 88 years old
it's weird that explains the story of
why they always looked in congruous to
me because as you point out he is a
[ __ ] greaser and they they were gospel
saying his dad's or his uncle's or
something like yeah that would make
sense their gospel says what are you do
for living I wear a checkered jacket and
go bop bop
and get a big [ __ ] check so blow me
said Gordon I stay home no jacket going
bop bop I make no money
and lastly richard griffiths passed away
this week
the age of 65 guy's a [ __ ] legend we
throw Richards picture up there you know
this guy may not know his name that
you'll recognize you know and of course
as Uncle Vernon from the Harry Potter
franchise Monty in that film was a boy
she won an Emmy for and also won an
Olivier in the UK for the production
over there he was one of the most
beloved most accomplished stage and
screen actors at England had to offer
passed away this week at 65 after
complications following heart surgery
very large man very light on his feet
like he could move around very well and
a very expressive in his acting and they
credited to the fact that he was raised
by two deaf mute parents so his first
language was sign language and he
learned the actors who worked with him
say he read faces and what you were
saying like nobody else like he was so
present the scene because he wasn't just
listening to you he'd learned growing up
to be in somebody's face and it made him
so much better at what he did it's a
really fantastic talent if you've ever I
mean of course he was in the Harry
Potter's and he's very charming and
funny in those but go back and watch
history boys go back way back and watch
with Nell in Iowa as the dudes losing
him as a [ __ ] lost man's ashamed he
was the guy in Naked Gun movies - it is
the wheelchair who goes flying across
the
like 18 remember that thing that's him
to do it abroad comedy series drama just
one of the good will be missed man it's
always sucks when we lose a fellow fatty
too so yeah that's that's a massive
[ __ ] lifetime of when by Richard so
sorry every week we take a look at
moments and TV shows and movies where
hundreds of pairs of eyes have taken a
look at this stuff and yet somehow [ __ ]
still slips through the cracks and gets
to you the viewer it's a segment we call
[ __ ] that should not be this week [ __ ]
that should not be
frankly I'm embarrassed it took us this
long to get to it and Damien from
Melbourne Australia called us out on
this and he's right and I apologized and
I thought this week with WonderCon being
right down the street and everything
you'll be appropriate to do one of the
all-time fuck-ups in movie history from
[ __ ] that should not be from one of the
great films of all time star wars as we
used to call it when I was a kid now I
guess it's known as episode 4 a new hope
a new hope yeah this is this is Luke
Skywalker himself this is Mark Hamill
he's just blown up the Death Star he's
very excited he flies back into the home
base from his x-wing fighter he's
looking for his sister does he know he's
just sister he's looking for the girl he
wants to [ __ ] Princess Leia and yet Mark
Hamill and all his excitement well the
following happens
yeah in case you missed that he calls
out Carrie and gives her a big hug
Carrie Fisher of course playing princess
Leah in that scene here's the thing and
Damien points us out and I recognize it
as well as that with all the extra stuff
added to all the special editions of all
the Star Wars we've seen since Lucas
never [ __ ] fixed that moment so he
can [ __ ] up good moments but he just
can't seem to [ __ ] to fix the fuck-ups
that's what George Lucas's and that's
why Disney put a gun to his head and
make him sign the contract there are
stormtroopers somewhere up on the right
there so we'll be that's why they bought
them they're like we don't care about
the movies we want the [ __ ] clones
that's right and again along with the
theory or rather the through-line that
we've had about the comic-con coming up
this weekend there is a moment in
exquisite acting I know we hit Nicolas
Cage pretty hard in this segment where
we take a look at at high-level
celebrities giving in less than a list
performances but this week's Nicolas
Cage moment I think is worthy of
exquisite acting this week's exquisite
acting features Nicolas Cage's
performance in kick-ass another comic
book movie since we're talking about
WonderCon a great performance I thought
and can you really the whole [ __ ]
performance you could say it is
exquisite acting cuz he's chewing the
[ __ ] scenery in an Adam West like way
but no moment more so than at the very
end when he's actually on fire talking
to his daughter well not do that part
it's not that the end end part it's the
part where that he just starts getting
on fire and he yells out to her which I
believe the line is take cover child and
switch to kryptonite is the line which
is one of the plans they have for he's
been training here all these years how
to cover the bad guys this is a [ __ ]
excellent comic in an excellent movie it
is all of those things but this
particular line delivery I think made
from bad all the way around - exquisite
acting
this is from Johnny and Kayden Edie
burrow Scotland they sent this one in
here for them
Nicolas Cage from kick-ass
[Music]
[Music]
I'm telling you man it's gonna take
about 20 maybe 30 years but people are
gonna go back and be like he was nothing
but genius
he never [ __ ] delivered a line the
way anybody else would
daddy much is true but that's he brought
his own spin to it even something as
simple as that people like you're dying
say [ __ ] switch to crib dies because
doesn't matter at all that nobody can
say what the [ __ ] he's saying does that
is that a problem in his head he's
sitting there going like I'm [ __ ]
dying I'm right fire I'm not gonna be
intelligible I'm trying to spit it out
before my last gas but it wouldn't sound
like switch to club tonight
uh-huh it would sound like you say so
Sparky keeping with the WonderCon theme
this week each and every week we have
you talented Hollywood babble-on
listeners a Photoshop your photos of
Kevin being in places where he shouldn't
be it's maybe my favorite segment of the
week it's known as keV in
what's Kevin this week well it's Kevin
cosplay it's as if Kevin if a Kevin was
at every comic-con you ever went to how
would Kevin look as Kevin in cosplay
I've been treat cosplay of course for
those of you who don't speak geek is
costume play it's people who dress up as
their favorite characters and go to
these Comic Cons and they enter in the
masquerade contest and win valuable
prizes and things like that or they just
go around in the street and just solicit
hookers this is what I did when I used
to dress up here's the first pic this is
Kevin as the kingpin legendary
spider-man and an Ironman Joe in the
kingpin posing with a fan and one of the
conventions very impressive you don't
look too happy about it keV but that is
why I will hold on every [ __ ] last
tear I have because that's what it's
gonna look like man just an endless head
that rolls into necklace
you've been twisted before oh [ __ ] I'm
double fisted there this character at
this particular comic this photo we're
showing you is the category called
silent boba I'm pretty cute pretty good
there is that's the first Kevin that I'm
like I agree with this silent boba Baba
and of course this photo was taken years
ago when Kevin and I were one of the
first Comic Cons Kevin I ever went to we
were both very young here's us as Batman
and Robin of course is my youthful
sidekick look at you working on there
[Music]
that's what I look like totally my was
getting [ __ ] but then you use that as a
[ __ ] or you were getting [ __ ] no man
I'm sexually active at 14 yes I was a
sexually active at 12 you lost your
virginity at 12 yeah I met somebody
who's really cool
I never knew this about I did but about
by age 13 I realized like [ __ ] it's
no good to just be look good you gotta
get you know bring something to the
table
they've men of my time or the boys of my
time particularly we're all about you
know first base kissing second base do
this which [ __ ] some I don't know any
lady that likes this but nobody ever
taught us like no get in there smooth
and [ __ ] you know make love and
suckle not funny thing [ __ ] like that
nobody tells you this con [ __ ] so third
base was just sawing at [ __ ] if you
could get to it and luckily I had a girl
that was just like now man [ __ ] like
you gotta know what you're doing down
there teacher well also like nobody
educates you like they know a dude knows
he comes right because you jerk off and
there's [ __ ] pretty produce something
there's a result it ends there's a
climax and [ __ ] but nobody you know
tells you like oh women could come too
just because they don't have something
shooting out of them and [ __ ] like that
so I had a girl who was just like you
gotta learn what you're doing man so at
age 12 I got this book a gynecological
textbook that I found at a state sale
like my mom this story gets weirder and
weirder I got an agent text from a dead
man and I open it up the dust cover book
reveal to me the secrets of the labrum
[Laughter]
quite action my father said it was a
doctor's house and so that you know
people died and they saw their entire
state and my mom worked for a company
that went in and liquidated houses of
[ __ ] so I would go in and work these
sales you need to stand in a room make
sure people aren't stealing [ __ ] or tell
people where to park him when I get like
five bucks for the day I was 12 years
old like 1982 I see this book guy and I
call it says gynecological studies or
something like that's a thick ass
textbook looked like it was from the 40s
or 50s opened it up drawings of vaginas
oh dude pictures of vagina but [ __ ]
50s vaginas so nothing but [ __ ] boy
oh sure first thing get a machete that's
what you thought to yourself
but that was where I learned I studied
the art of the female body and learned
how to make women come this is the
clitoris search for the g-spot and all
this [ __ ] [ __ ] Wow
and so when I was about 13 I was like a
[ __ ] lick master from the Orient man
I knew what the [ __ ] cuz I was very and
also it took a few more years for me to
realize like women could come just from
sex like I thought it was only from oral
so I was one of those [ __ ] a
gang way cuz I want to make sure they
came first right of them how slobbering
ly grateful I was to be getting any
action there and so that they always
thought in the future one lonely night
there like none of the cool guys are
calling me but that fat boy a [ __ ] real
well so they [ __ ] call me back that's
great sorry anyway back to the show now
we all know way more than we ever wanted
to about Kevin Smith I just started you
found a 12 year old you at 12 years old
you found a woman who was willing yeah
yeah you should be arrested see bad bad
plugin bad I should live in [ __ ]
Jersey eyes right across the river for
you in Philadelphia no 12 year olds were
putting out when I was well when did you
when did you lose 16 like a normal human
being like a regular person I wasn't a
pervert like you for [ __ ] sake this is
even weirder man here all at the
ultimate - this is gonna make me sound
stupid and I didn't grow up like [ __ ]
but this is gonna sound this is Ben I'm
sorry how did you grow up again
sound so like [ __ ] hillbilly it's
nuts
I I didn't I had sex at 12 and didn't
realize I did until I was 16 you didn't
know you had had sex once again dude
nobody ever sits you down we kids now
are educated you got the internet or you
got parents they'll sit you down and
[ __ ] tell you [ __ ]
my parents didn't tell me anything
[ __ ] Catholic I was went to Catholic
school they didn't [ __ ] tell us
anything except don't ever touch it you
know right so nobody [ __ ] educate you
so to me the definition of sex I almost
had a Clintonian definition of sex
before Bill Clinton my definition of sex
was sex only happens if you come inside
the woman so I've been like me and this
girl had been like [ __ ] I've been
entered stuff and then I'd pull out and
come and I'd be like we're still virgins
you should add a priest good a same
logic so by town replace girl with boy
and you did a bit of brave you had to
take it dirty and a Catholic and [ __ ]
like that but that yeah but sixteen
that's so funny somebody was just like
with the moment you're inside and sex
yeah elegance early bloomer in sex in
penis apparently well that's the end of
our show folks no no we've got more show
fist up with like we're gonna do the
real show right now it's everywhere just
doing love lines I know every week we
also like to take a look at the biggest
stories in the world of show business
the entertainment news headlines in a
section we call the HBO headlines
no bigger star in the headlines this
week than Justin Bieber himself we've
been featuring him every week no without
trust me we all in this room hate him
there's no need to voice your
disapproval we've been talking about him
so much that we've talked about the fact
that we need a jingle for this habit
well the fans have gone nuts the
listeners have gone crazy and been
sending in a ton of jingles I've sifted
through most of them I came to these
three oh so we're gonna take a listen to
a couple of them and see what you think
here's the first one from Jim Laskowski
he he wrote this one
[Music]
yeah that's it
maybe a little long for long so No let
me fix this one from Buzz Compton Buzz
Compton from Germany yeah I'm very hip
over yeah yeah yeah I am best Compton
and everybody said very cool yeah with
Germany y'all need to be pissed of all
about stats right cuz my name is buzz
I'm like one of the American astronaut
you know but this straight that of cop
tears right and and turn me right but
you know the name Compton makes you
think other Schwartz's you know here's
buzz Compton's jingle for Bieber that's
it you missed it while you're being rude
laughing at Germany that's what happened
can we replay that one for people who
are rude and laughing at Germany James
[Music]
[Laughter]
brevity being the soul of wit man that's
the strong contenders yeah and rich
Williams from London and Birmingham in
the UK he said it would be great under
who's this in the pop scrotums news
section ever we're gone the paper the
bombs pop scrotum
here's here's riches
[Music]
I think the people of spoken man the
winner right there winter wearing check
it better yeah it's as if the Cure did a
jingle for [ __ ] Brits why are they so
much cooler than us it's the accent you
could whip a concert the end and it
sounds you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
lights out Bieber in the news this week
here's the thing he came back from
overseas his tour which was a [ __ ]
disaster he passed out he tried to punch
a guy in the UK his bodyguard had to put
him back in his car see it was a
nightmare he gets back from there and he
gets his new Ferrari delivered to his
front door because you know he's got a
friend of his name will twist as a
rapper who just guzzles sizzurp and
crashes his Ferrari so he had to get a
new one
he gets a new one and he starts driving
around the neighborhood he lives in
Calabasas which is for those you don't
know Southern California it's about no
no 45 minutes north of here very nice
residential community people move there
to get away from [ __ ] people like
Justin Bieber they're living in this
neighborhood and he starts driving his
ferrari around the neighborhood a
hundred miles an hour at 8 o'clock in
the morning so one of the neighbors
comes out it's got three kids this guy
comes on says look you can't drive like
this in this neighborhood there's
children here it's 8 o'clock in the
morning that the car makes a horrible
noise you're being rude justin bieber
again reporting from this 47 year old
father of three said get the [ __ ] out of
here
I'm gonna [ __ ] kill you said Bieber
well actually didn't say that what do
you say
and then he spits in the guy's face no
what the [ __ ] really man you don't get
to spit in anybody's face unless you the
[ __ ] bat man you just killed the
Joker in the tunnel of love those are
the only time I've said for many years
I'd rather be peed on than spit on yeah
yeah would that be weird man because
that's almost funny that's funny a guy
whips out his penis starts peeing on you
I can almost laugh at that Oh bit of my
face it's [ __ ] game on
and also somebody's peeing I've somebody
spits on you you've got no time to
capture the moment it happens and [ __ ]
somebody peeing on you got so much time
now I'm gonna find this so uh needles to
say Bieber's people saying oh that
didn't happen at all but the guy Lodge
logged a complaint with the authorities
the police are investigating this Bieber
wasn't somebody it was not it wasn't one
of his crew it was Bieber and they're
looking into it they're investigating
and the authorities say we take this
very seriously because not only is
spitting just [ __ ] rude no but you
can its communicable diseases and [ __ ]
who knows what he's got blowing monkeys
in Germany or whatever
oh really yeah he'd put a banana on his
forehead so the monkey would come close
Bieber just came back from overseas in
an unrelated story it turns out these
singers pet monkey was quarantined in
Germany he's got a capuchin monkey Mike
little one Michael a real [ __ ] pop
star had a full-blown mother [ __ ]
chimpanzee who could rip your face off
kill you then [ __ ] the corpse Bieber
lightweight that he is has a little
capuchin monkey as one of those friends
monkeys Marcel remember a little monkey
would jump around on the [ __ ] diaper
on yeah one of those and he's got a tour
with it naturally because I think the
monkey is his band conductor shows up in
Germany with the monkey and the Germans
are like there's no route you can bring
your foreign monkeys in here yeah you
can't bring now because monkeys have
diseases yeah but he's a bad deity yeah
and you know if you don't like here you
to bring your monkey in here and with
all the [ __ ] diseases
so nine wouldn't actually pay so we had
to leave it behind with the customs when
he wanted to tour in Germany and
according to all accounts you never know
we can find any mention of the monkey in
Munich no Munich monkey you never leave
a monkey behind bosses lost with the
Munich monkey he got so excited he
forgets to speak English
so no papers monkey still in Europe at
large
Bieber's monkey at large right on man
and when people was returning from from
Europe to the States he left out of
Poland and there was a big deal made
about the fact that while he was at the
Polish Airport all the planes were
facing the wrong way
no I'm kidding I'm kidding oh you
[ __ ] Paul off you're so serious no he
was in Poland and he was going through
security and he went through shirtless
with his pants down around his knees did
you see these photos no let's take a
look at Justin going through security in
Poland I [ __ ] you not this was not lit
security saying all right son stripped
down to your skivvies he did this
himself picture dude that looks like
that moment from less than zero we're
[ __ ] Robert Downey jr. is blown of
guising I thought it was cool I'm swag
yo and he went topless into the Polish
airport I went through security with no
no shirt on and at least you can't see
it here because it looks like he's you
know he's got no pants on these are his
pants down here around his thighs and he
walked through the entire airport like
that for the entire afternoon and by the
way it was 14 degrees in Poland that day
he must be must be on something right or
he's missing his monkey I'm thinking
he's sitting there protesting the loss
of his monkey by taking my shirt off and
Jack my pants down I imagine his pants
are down like that
all the time that's where he wears that
swag but once you take your shirt off no
not that the Biebs it's like I have to
my pants come down because they can't
stay up cuz the gun pushes them down
yeah
this gentleman could easily hike
straight absolutely where he could wear
tight pants that are form-fitting around
his buttocks and he would be fine what's
he rebelling against what do you got
sexy Bieber apparently very upset this
photograph has made the Internet he's
also upset about the photographs from
the UK or show him being put back in his
car seat he wants those off the internet
so there's been a whole new group of
people now we're putting together
photoshopped photos of Justin Bieber
saying Justin Bieber wants this picture
off the photo has become a meme on the
Internet
this is my favorite one I thought I'd
bring it in Justin Bieber what's this
off the internet it says it's Bieber and
Ray J which is a [ __ ] tape star Kim
Kardashian's boyfriend someone
photoshopped them together and made a
thing out of it I say let that live on
the Internet forever yeah that is
definitely Photoshop yeah one of my new
favorites also made it into the showbiz
news this week and she has a theme and
she has a theme amanda Bynes is back
[Applause]
[Music]
Amanda leave me alone Bynes back in the
news this week she wants to be left
alone you [ __ ] she's not a TV star
anymore she is she's a private person
and she wants to be left alone that's
why she tweets things like this
I want Drake to murder my vagina she's
got a crush on Jake Oh Drake I'm sorry I
almost sobered up there for a minute is
that what the kids are saying these days
murder Moggridge I've never heard that
before yeah well I thought maybe that
was in your book from 1947 maybe you
would have found that in there remember
boys you always want to murder the
vagina she has a crush on Drake yeah the
pop star Drake and she would like him
I'm guessing from her tweet if I'm not
missing it to murder her vagina but
don't pay any attention to me right
Amanda ads she also tweeted last week
where wait any ladies out here is
anybody use that phrase murder my vagina
who where where wait but that sounded
like a dude or a dude as a woman used
that with you sir we said [ __ ] murder
my vagina not man John cuz I bet you
there are a lot of dudes who like murder
my mangina dude thing to say but I could
never imagine a girl being like Oh
murder the [ __ ] in my vagina he was
on [ __ ] your show wasn't he Drake
yeah it was under grassy Degrassi they
played Jimmy Jimmy got shot and wanted a
richer but now he's murdering a vagina
so he's better off be honest though and
this is gonna sound suck-up me but I
always felt this he was such an amazing
actor on that show like he was clearly
more intuitive than most people yet he's
if you go back and watch yeah [ __ ] I'm
not sure I don't want him to murder my
vagina
I'm just paying a complan you go back
and watch the early seasons into grass
in the next generation he shines he's a
really good actor
she also tweeted last week I created the
phrase LOLOL she's taking credit for lol
yeah that's weird on two levels number
one like no you didn't number two why
would you take credit right
she also tweeted if I'm not following
you on Twitter I hate you
she wrote yeah man it desperately wants
to be left alone that's why she was seen
wearing this outfit around Times Square
this week that was a crushed velvet
skirt she's wearing bare legs a fur
topped hoodie a fake wig she found out
that she was being watched though she
ducked into a McDonald's restaurant
where she immediately ordered a coffee
and a coke and started drinking the both
simultaneously like Templars no two
straws in her mouth simultaneously she's
got to be conducting some sort of
experiment right yeah it's how [ __ ]
crazy can I be and then as she was
leaving the Macdonald she knows her
people out there with cameras so she put
on this blue button-down shirt over her
head the only problem is witnesses in
Times Square says she kept walking into
[ __ ] yeah one onlooker said it looked
like she was pretending to be a ghost
she kept waving her arms in front of
herself running into light posts and
walls avoiding attracting attention to
her itself
Amanda we've missed you god bless she's
back in the news this week
[Music]
I'm gonna hit this quick because we have
like 47 Lindsay Lohan stories to get bro
first of all we found out from a stores
close to her legal team that when she
was dealing with that lying to cops
charged in court in Santa Monica the
only thing she told her legal team was
make sure I don't have to go to rehab
before Coachella that's what she said
she made a point was the only marching
order she gave her legal team was make
sure I get to go to the Coachella Valley
Arts and Music Festival in April so I
can get [ __ ] up before I go into rehab
I'm using that as advertising on the
Billboard before I go to rehab I'm going
to coach I'm here before you go to jail
she was on anger management she did a
guest starring role on the Charlie Sheen
show anger management and she had to go
clubbing naturally the before she left
the set she decided to help herself to a
bracelet a necklace earrings pants and
shoes from the wardrobe department
that's right she stole [ __ ] from the
wardrobe department of anger management
this is a group of people that are used
to dealing with Charlie Sheen on a daily
basis and this crew said it was the
worst experience they've ever had
working with someone no really when she
rapped when she was done with her final
shot this is according to TMZ calm when
she was wrapped and did her final shot
on the set the crew burst out into
applause when they said she was leaving
but not as like she's graduation good
you're a [ __ ] nightmare get out of my
life that kind of a Buffalo exchange
she says her people are saying well
Lindsay was under the understanding that
whatever she stole I'm sorry
took from wardrobe would be with
withdrawn from her salary that's how
they would work that out the producers
say that was not the deal at all they
had with miss Lohan and my favorite
story of the week featuring Lindsay is
she's now currently in Sao Paulo Brazil
promoting a clothing line there she's
being paid six figures to show up and
promote the clothing line she's also
been going to the nightclubs I'm sure
just for research and
apparently people there at the nightclub
were asking to take photos with her and
so Lindsey being an adult woman
responded the only way she knew how she
crawled under the table that she was
drinking at that's a cry for help right
there man no it's a cry for [ __ ] right
there is what that is
I guess if you're a he's a [ __ ] level if
you're standing up she's a [ __ ] level
you don't hug him why you gotta bring
math into it was late in the game
another one of our familiar favorites
Kim Kardashian I'm sorry
[ __ ] tape star Kim Kardashian's in the
news
the Kardashians are upset this week
because a photo of an ad from Ford
Motors made the internet this week it
was an Indian advertising campaign I saw
this is weird they're they're trying to
promote their new car in India for it is
it's called the let me get this straight
the Richard Barker
no it's not it's called the Figo the
Figo and they claim it has an expansive
back-end why is it called the Figo not
the JLo or the Kim Kardashian for that
matter I was hoping I would have went
over better they did a sketch of Lindsay
Lohan Lindsay Lohan that Paris Hilton
driving this car with the Kardashians
tied up and bound in the trunk with the
premise being leave your worries behind
with the Figo's extra-large trunk as if
if Paris Hilton was tired of it getting
all the press and so she's got them
bound up and ready to murder in the
trunk of their car here's here's the the
ad itself from this Indiana it's a
Skinner's Paris and they're they the
Kardashian girls ready to be murdered
who could take offense to this
well apparently Chloe did an attorney
for the Kardashians said the leave your
worries behind for dads are disgusting
vile and offensive from the [ __ ]
Kardashians yes I didn't I'm not I don't
watch this and every time you tell the
story I'm just like wow so weird I don't
know anybody watches the show I found
somebody who [ __ ] watches the show at
[ __ ] Ground Zero in my house too what
my kid watches Keeping Up with the car
and then one day I finally I said I was
just like what the [ __ ] man I was like
really and she's like yeah I watch it
all the time I was like why why would
you watch that she goes dad it's
hysterical and I go oh you're breakin my
heart man like what do you mean it's
hysterical she's like the one boy Rob
he's such a loser company with the
sisters and she starts laughing like
they're characters on a sitcom and I was
I was just like oh I see why you like it
you think it's funny I said but these
people are [ __ ] for real she's like
no they're actors he did try to start a
designer sock company who the [ __ ] does
that you know what I have this Armani
suit oh you don't really need though I
need a [ __ ] designer line of socks to
put on before I put my shoes on who does
that
stupid people do that and they sees him
as a modern-day Jack Tripper dude she
thinks yeah the Kardashian lawyer said
that this ad was disgusting vile and
offensive and I can see why be upset in
an unrelated story the Kardashians this
week on their show Kourtney and Kim Take
Miami had a [ __ ] smelling contest now
let's start watching the show of my kid
man holy crap Chloe
[Music]
told his knee is gonna build us every
time we use that now told Kourtney and
Kim and Kourtney and Kim Take Miami
they'd be drinking of pineapple juice
that makes your vagina smell wonderfully
so I know it makes to come taste good
right sir yes I know we know the truth
about pineapple juice that's the same
guy that was like murder my mangina I
murder vaginas with my sweet-tasting
comb I gotta introduce you to PI over
here and Rosa up there and Richard Baca
and we could come to and people Spanky
so Kourtney and Kim have a bed about
whose [ __ ] smells better this is on
[ __ ] TV this [ __ ] happened this
was broadcast they think the ad was
[ __ ] vile and disgusting they're
smelling each other's [ __ ] on this show
well let me tell you Kevin so Kim and
Kourtney say well my [ __ ] smells better
no sister my [ __ ] smells better this is
a [ __ ] television show how do I do it
well let me take a cloth napkin I'm
gonna rub my [ __ ] all over a cloth
napkin and I'm gonna bring it out oh
well really well I'll rub my [ __ ] with
a big cloth napkin hold on hold on say
it slower well who's gonna be the judge
Kourtney I don't know Kim who's gonna
smell our [ __ ] smells hey Chloe what
are you doing this this week
well han Solo gave me the week off so I
dance I'll smell your [ __ ] for you
everybody give me your cloth napkins and
I'll sniff them and I'll see who's got
the best smelling [ __ ] like me I'm
Lewis Black
[Applause]
[Music]
so Courtney mother of two goes up
against Kim Kardashian has had every
[ __ ] guy you can imagine just
murdering her [ __ ] they they smear
themselves all over cloth napkins and
they present them like they're this Jack
it's the [ __ ] glass slipper to
Cinderella they bring it up to Chloe and
they say sister tell me what do you
think of it here comes Kim's vagina
Chloe by the way declared Kim the winner
of the best smelling vagina competition
of the Kardashian family yeah I'm sure
after ray Jay's been slamming away at it
and Kanye and Kris Humphries and of you
and me everybody's just been it's just
so funny I was on television it's
somewhere that their shows like I loved
a show Pushing Daisies so much very
similar and they're each and it's
struggled to get [ __ ] ratings and
[ __ ]
yeah that's gone they cancelled it but
this shit's on the air which is like
snot my [ __ ] all over it but I'm just
like Southland isn't is in danger of
being canceled on TNG couldn't be bigger
right there if they called the show
smell my [ __ ] I would totally tuned in
every
that sounds like a game show that you
should host actually no I see I wish the
other one had been in on the Wookiee
chick because then I could have been
like let the wookie win she can rip
their arms up can you imagine the
visible fumes that would have come off
that cloth napkin it would have been
like that shimmering heat kind of thing
in a like a Miami asphalt you know on
the distance when you're driving through
Florida in August you were seeing that
just at that shimmer - coming off of it
what's even weirder is like Kim
Kardashian came out with hers and like
tried to shove it in her sister's face
in the way that like a Jason Mewes would
do to you if he was like smell my finger
and [ __ ] like that
speaking of reality television the duck
dynasty boys are in the news this week
oh go [ __ ] yourself
it's no better it's no better than the
[ __ ] smelling show it's this the
toothless make a duck decoy show is what
it is however it is earning eight point
six million viewers a week
take the camera point it down south man
that's all America wants to watch is
what's going down below they're ready to
make the fourth season of duck dynasty
because we all can't wait to see if they
make another [ __ ] duck call or not
but the family the Robertson family
isn't so eager to shoot the next one
they want two hundred thousand dollars
in episodes
what a piece no for the family they're
gonna split it up you know I don't know
if 40,000 per tooth I guess for each of
them that's not like [ __ ] friends
money or something like but these guys
we're living in the swamp carving [ __ ]
out of wood weren't they already well
the business is doing very well and it's
doing even better because of the
promotion from the show so they're
they're very comfortable right now but
now they want more from A&E and ain't
news you know the same [ __ ] we got to
find Dumber cheaper southerners now or
or they're probably gonna do the obvious
which is like [ __ ] it break it off man
we're pulling that
kind of rating numbers I can give them
that they want I mean - hi Sally
they were like 200 apiece then it'd be
like you guys are nuts but 200 - split
amongst the family and stuff when
they're pulling that kind of rating the
reason you do a reality show is because
it's cheap yeah until it's not but it's
like every it's it's following the same
model of every TV show which is you
start at one budget by the time you're
in fucking's if you make it to season
ten you're so successful you have to
stop because it's too [ __ ] expensive
to do though it seems like it's
happening now for reality shows as well
those guys may get their money you know
who got his money this week our old
friend
our old friend Jose Martinez the the
paraplegic who was stuck on the small
world ride at Disneyland never had to
Disney because for those who don't know
the story he was stuck on the it's a
small world ride man uses a wheelchair
he was stuck in the boat everyone else
got out because the ride broke down but
he was stuck inside the ride for hours
while the song played over and over and
over again while he was stuck in the
boat we talked about the story when it
first happened he first when he first
filed his lawsuit we talked about it and
we felt it looked a little something
like this
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
finally they finally got his day in
court and he did win he did win the jury
for him the jury awarded him $8,000
that's right
the duck [ __ ] makers are making 200
grand and Jose stranded there on that
boat made eight grand how long he was
there a couple hours stranding him for a
half hour while the theme played eight
grand for a half hour I want that gun a
sweet money man it felt longer I would
imagine the judge said that it was a
half for pain and suffering and half for
violating the disability law because
they couldn't get him out of the boat
when the when the thing broke down does
it help that long before [ __ ] right
because Walt Disney hated cripples
that's a fact that is a fact that has
been documented Walt hated [ __ ]
cripples in the wonderful world of
Disney everybody walked that's right
[Music]
[Laughter]
Jose said he suffers from panic attacks
high blood pressure which was aggravated
because he needed to urinate while he
was in the boat this go exactly sir
that's what I do when I'm in small world
right over the side of the boat it's a
world of you're in a world of flying
fish hey you know we may need a new
closing segment for this show because
this week all everyone's been talking
about is jon Hamm's [ __ ] I heard Jon
Hamm star of mass Mad Men people just
talking about his [ __ ] can't stop
talking about his [ __ ] here we are
trying to build up a little heat for
Liam Neeson's [ __ ] and meanwhile jon
Hamm's [ __ ] take and all that he's
public run two hands [ __ ] coming up
from behind that's right
it started with a New York Daily News
article that said they spoke to an AMC
insider who said they're currently
filming the upcoming season of Mad Men
and because it takes place in the in the
late sixties clothes are tighter now and
Jon Hamm likes to go commando and his
penis is distracting so the producers
had to ask him politely pull him aside
and ask him to wear underwear because
his massive [ __ ] is too distracting
what is underwear gonna do well it'll
keep it into a package it'll hold it up
into a package instead of down his leg
dangling the wigs benefit we're okay
with your [ __ ] just wrap it just make a
bolt we need Don Draper should have a
bolt he shouldn't have a salami hanging
down the inside of his thigh now I
didn't know this but apparently there's
been a tumblr called jon Hamm's Hwang
that's been going on for two years now
so we're late to the John Hancock game
John talked about it in an interview
with Rolling Stone magazine this month
who said most of his tongue in cheek but
it's a little rude they're called
privates for a reason I'm wearing pants
for [ __ ] sake I mean lay off I'm
talking about how big your [ __ ] is
unappreciative mother's downside in that
oh please stop talking about how huge
and luscious and satisfactory in like a
baby's arm holding an apple like [ __ ]
Dumbo's trunk my dick is rude when
people feel the freedom to create tumblr
accounts about my [ __ ] I feel like that
wasn't part of the deal he says
regarding being an actor it is in the
21st century dude jockey and fruit of
the Loom underwear by the way I've
offered him a lifetime supply in order
to keep his massive [ __ ] fat juicy
[ __ ] just somehow harness from keeping
from raping and pillaging its way
through neighborhoods photographic funny
you should ask Kevin because you know
those of us here at Hollywood babble-on
are always fascinated by a good
celebrity [ __ ] so I went over to jon
Hamm's Wang myself and my wife by the
way curious about my my internet history
this week let's take a look at jon
Hamm's wang shall we this is Jon Hamm
walking with his lovely girlfriend here
can we use can we get a closer picture
of this year this is this is down the
inside of his leg on his leg if you're
thinking if it's stuck if it starts here
let's imagine it starts here yeah this
is the integrin
this is what we're talking you can see
the ridge and [ __ ] he's cut yeah stop
talking about my massive amazing [ __ ]
that women love he's [ __ ] not mad man
he's happy man that's right mr. t I love
[ __ ] mr. t you know I don't know it's
very uncomfortable
[Laughter]
the reason I bring it up cuz you and I
both hockey fans did you see him this
week at the at the Blackhawks game I did
not I just wanted to bring it up because
he sees mr. t he's I don't know he's a
hundred now and he's he no longer pities
the fool he's just he's just he's an
older man who's just trying to get by
and trying to milk whatever little level
of fame he has left to make a buck they
add him at the Chicago Blackhawks
Calgary Flames game this week and they
put him in the one of the intermissions
to have him be the celebrity guy who
shoots the puck at the net and no one
does well on that it's embarrassing and
he's old and he's wearing a bandana and
he's got chains on it's sad but
something magical happened here's mr. t
taking a shot at the goal during the
intermission between the first and
second periods at the Blackhawks game
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's all five-hole ma'am yeah did he win
something or somebody win something that
he won him for him or something no they
they gave him a space heater for his box
no he's got a cardboard box outside the
arena and they just put a space heater
minute a fool can't stay warm minute a
fool has no newspaper to cover himself
up with a woman you should've never came
back let me show you how real man
satisfy you my prediction I've only
[ __ ] Stallone was they were fighting
in the last one and he just kept putting
his hand on his mohawk yeah I remember
being a kid and being like off I could
be that [ __ ] badass that [ __ ] you're
in the middle of the fight for your life
this dude's beat you before you're so
[ __ ] confident you've trained so well
that you're just like it's gonna book
him you're gonna mock in watch that
movie but my wife she don't like the
Rocky movies of them what they're the
best movies ever she's my mother my wife
hates every [ __ ] movie with a guy in
the lead she said you know they stupid
boy movie every movies best a boy with
problems who wins opposites attract
I guess yeah you should have married
Paul Abdul then how dare you sir
Smith and I of course longtime geeks
every week we like to take a look at the
geek news James
[Music]
this week in geek news I was shocked and
stunned by this geek news talking about
the cast of the next Captain America
film Captain America to Winter Soldier
the Winter Soldier
can't wait in there they cast Robert
Redford in the film that's what really
is who he's gonna play one of the
executives at the Law Enforcement Agency
shield a character named Pearce he's
gonna play one of the higher-ups at
shield that's cool that's very cool he's
white like 70 something at this point
yeah but he still looks good in a Marvel
movie that makes a movie immediately
meant that much cooler also just like go
back 20 [ __ ] years man or even
[ __ ] maybe 10 years at this point
nobody was jumping into comic book
movies Jack Nicholson had to pay him a
[ __ ] king's ransom and 50% of like
randos joker brando did superman they
gave him a pile of money too they gave
him $1,000,000 1977 but now we live in a
day and age where something like Robert
Redford who's one of the most respected
filmmakers actors of all time yeah it's
like I'm gonna be in a comic book movie
that's right it's a cool thing for
accountable he said this is the kind of
film I'd like to see when I was a kid
that's why he's doing it [ __ ] yeah he's
older forever when Captain Eric was
actually fighting the Nazis he truly is
George st. Pierre the UFC fighter he has
been announced he's gonna play Batroc
the leaper oh really yeah worst [ __ ]
villain in the history of Marvel Comics
you know what I do i oh hello superhero
I'm not going to leap at you AHA now I'm
going to leap backwards you can't catch
me because I leap he's the leaper that's
his [ __ ] superpower as he leaps a lot
yeah what you know they ran out of [ __ ]
powers a certain point like this guy he
just jumps this guy he's the Walker
what's he do he gets one place to
another
it's the Angelo the stroller yes I am I
gonna stroll away from you you cannot
get you me look at me i stroller
Captain America [ __ ] you I gotta go bye
summer pizza bye bye now
it was that someone's miss city it's
Captain America always that'll be from
some other country
I'm the French Ally / I will leap at you
huh what about the Diedrich and Franz
the the [ __ ] joggers yeah be just
John there are HR all the time you can
catch us yeah if a villain jogs a very
good catch that's right in lederhosen
and GM is announced a Tomb Raider reboot
they just bought the rights for Tomb
Raider they're gonna make more Lara
Croft movies and speaking of hot the
porn business once again has trumped
reality there you have just announced
the Wonder Woman xxx the porn parody oh
there's nothing funny about that sir my
penis has already gone on to Netflix
looking for how to get it Wonder Woman
in a porn movie it's the culmination of
my my lifetime dreams
it's the comics and the porn crossing at
the most perfect way axel Braun the guy
who does all these comic book porn
movies he's the one who's directing and
he released a still of his Wonder Woman
an actress named Kimberly Kane
it's iterative part of the Batman family
but she's Kimberly Cain she's Wonder
Woman this is the photo of the new
Wonder Woman from the porn version oh
she looks cute she looks [ __ ] great
if I was gonna cast a straight version
Wonder Woman movie I would put her in
and that costume finally looks like a
costume that someone could actually wear
and not be thought of as cheesy or
stupid in fact remember the David E
Kelly TV version they were gonna do with
Adrianne Palicki hands let's put them
side to side and see which one looks
like the porn movie version
[Laughter]
Kelly's Frederick's of Hollywood for
Halloween and the porn one looks
legitimate looks like the slogan should
be like justice is anal she'll stick
bullets and bracelets up your ass
she's Wonder Woman yeah Steve Trevor
never had it so good so that's the
that's the new porn Wonder Woman I'm
looking forward to it I'm a people out
man you don't like the porn parodies no
but I'll people out regardless you
didn't watch the clerks porn parody yet
I've yet to watch I'm gonna watch it
though away you jerk off to it yeah
especially if there's a Silent Bob
character I find attractive I've always
wanted to do that man I've seen a lot of
people on Twitter of reported not only
like oh it's [ __ ] hot and fun but a
lot of people like dude it's so true to
clerks it's nuts like I have watched it
by those and they do a lot of omage is
to like the script and the storyline is
stuff it's kind of fun I'm a man stop it
I can masturbate if I want to
speaking of masturbation each and every
week we like to take a look at another
celebrity penis we might have to change
this bit to Jon Hamm but always stick by
our celebrity car Liam Neeson here's the
[ __ ] that we like to talk about
[Music]
of course you can go to Neeson [ __ ] calm
yourself if you'd like to add any facts
about the size of Liam Neeson's [ __ ] not
to be confused with jon Hamm's Wang I
want to thank Liz Gleason from Rochester
New York for kicking us off this week
she said in a photo and I [ __ ] you not
this was a photo she took while she was
walking she was hiking through her
neighborhood of Rochester New York with
his dog she sent us this photo she said
seriously she saw this and she wanted to
send it along to let us know that the
word is spreading here's the photo that
she saw the drainpipe and somebody had
spray-painted Liam's [ __ ] was here more
of that as an entertainer it's nice to
know you're making the difference our
comedy is changing the landscape when
you walk through a door hold your head
up high alright let's take a look at
Liam Neeson's [ __ ] facts this week Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is so big what it visited
Germany customs let it keep its monkey
leave mrs. [ __ ] is so big that explorers
recently discovered a previously unknown
culture living on the tip but has
adapted to extremely high altitude and
is completely unaware of modern
civilization let's take a breath
[Music]
mrs. [ __ ] is so big a man returned
taking two to Redbox three days ago Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is still in his living
room all right fair enough Liam Neeson's
[ __ ] is so big it killed his trainer at
Sea World and no one said a thing he
added so shut your [ __ ] mouth Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is so big it's what caused
Stella to lose her groove in the first
place mom Joe yeah Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is
so big the Supreme Court ruled that
same-sex couples are legally married if
it performs the ceremony
and lastly Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big
if you pull back its foreskin you will
find The Wizard of Oz operating it
ladies and gentlemen The Hollywood have
had a good time thank you so much for
coming out tonight we really do
appreciate you being here with us thanks
for being here thanks for selling it out
give it up for the amazing man the host
of the show mr. Babylon I'm so proud
Ghana of course my partner and the man
who's smoking all that sweet sweet cush
mr. Kevin Smith everybody and that is
Hollywood babble-on for this week I'm
Kevin Smith I'm Ralph Garman babble to
[ __ ] off good night Los Angeles
ladies and gentlemen give it up one more
time for Ralph Garman and Kevin Smith
[Music]